if you want to change your life it
begins right here every single morning
there is a powerful skill that I want
you to learn when that alarm rings you
have got to get out of bed look I know
there's a million reasons not to get out
of bed right now this morning I can
think of a bunch it's 40° raining
disgusting cold depressing outside I
feel tired my bones feel heavy I have a
lot of work to do and it's uh stressing
me out a little bit none of that stuff
matters the only thing that matters when
it comes to changing your life is can
you keep a promise to yourself can you
keep a promise to yourself when it feels
uncomfortable that is the core skill
that you need to change any area of your
life because change doesn't require
motivation it requires discipline you
need the discipline to do what you said
you were going to do and I want you to
think about this hey it's EV Carmichael
and I watch these videos every day
because I need them for motivation being
around successful entrepreneurs every
morning helps me believe that I can do
great things too it's like your morning
coffee but for your goals kickstarting
your day with a blast of positivity so
here is a challenge for you try watching
One video every morning for the next 30
days and let's find out together if they
help you do great things too if you're
in leave a # believe in the comments
below so I can celebrate with
you so today let's get some incredible
motivation from the one and only Mel
Robins enjoy when you set an
alarm setting an alarm the night before
is an act of making a promise to
yourself setting alarm which I do I get
up between 6:15 and
645 every day I am making a promise to
myself that I am going to get up when
that alarm
rings and if I can't keep a promise to
myself because I don't feel like it I'm
cranky I'm not a morning pran whatever
the hell your excuse
is you're not going to be able to keep
promises to yourself in any area of your
life where you feel
uncomfortable where it's easier to avoid
conflict where you succumb to your
excuses where you soothe yourself
instead of pushing through and I mean
this all change happens the same way
with discipline all change begins with
the decision to change all change begins
with making and keeping promises so
regardless of what you're working on if
you're working on boundaries if you're
working on saying no if you're working
on pushing yourself through
discomfort you can start to practice the
skill of showing up for yourself No
Matter What by simply setting the alarm
the night before for the when the time
you actually need to get up and when
that time comes and that alarm rings and
it's time to keep that promise no matter
what you're feeling your number number
one job is to keep that promise to
yourself the decision that aligns and is
true for you is the one that is going to
feel more expansive like that something
inside you opens up it doesn't mean it's
an easy decision doesn't mean that there
aren't things you're concerned about but
that it's going to create
growth that there's something exciting
even if it's scary about that decision
that there's some expansive energy to it
and that's how you can feel in your
heart and in your gut that that is a
decision that's aligned with who you are
and where you're meant to
go if you are making a decision and you
feel yourself shrink a little yeah you
feel the energy go down you feel kind of
instead of the expansion like this kind
of
contraction of energy that's a no
it's a no and that's why I opened up our
conversation by saying I think this is
going to be a short conversation because
you already
know and one other piece of advice I'm
going to give you is this when making
decisions in life always use your
heart to know what the truth is for you
this idea of a substitution diet for the
you've been thinking forever that no
longer serves you that's a simple way
for me to explain to you you you're not
stuck with the thoughts that you
think that idea right
there
that's the whole
thing that's
everything you are not stuck with the
thoughts that you
think you can let them rise up but you
don't have to grab them and grip onto
them and wrestle them to the ground you
be like oh there's that stupid thought
that my dad taught me to think bye dad
I choose to think something else because
I know what cognitive bias modification
is and that horse that you said that I
was a failure or didn't Mount up to
something or wasn't wanted I don't
believe that anymore because it's
important to me to not only see hearts
but it's important to me to encourage
myself to believe in myself to believe
in my life and my effort and my ability
because that's what I believe that's why
I'm
here you can do this if I can do this
you can do this stuff here's what
everybody gets wrong about
manifesting everybody at least kind of
in the mass Market what you're trained
to think about when you think about
manifesting is vision boards and when
you hear the word vision boards you
think about the big stuff should you
have big dreams of course you should
should you dream of building a mansion
on the ocean if that's your thing yes
yes should you dream of the Log Cabin
yes if you want a Lamborghini or the new
Ford bronos should you put yeah yes yes
yes if you want the family if you want
the body should you think about yeah
absolutely here's where everybody goes
wrong you dream about the end you make
this gorgeous collage of all this stuff
that has nothing to do with your current
life that literally is you're sitting in
your studio apartment with the cat box
that hasn't been changed in 2 weeks no
food
no food in the fridge and you're looking
for a job and you're staring at a
mansion going
someday it's going to make you feel like
a loser because the gap between where
you are and where you want to go seems
insurmountable and so what happens based
on the research is when you only
visualize the endgame Lewis it's
demotivating at first it's really fun to
like have a bottle of wine and make your
like collage I'm going visualize I'm
going slap this up there's my vision
board this fabulous love attraction baby
come on I'm think about it it's going to
come to
me okay I've been doing this for two
days I'm not I'm still in this apartment
with the cap box that needs to be
changed the way to visualize properly is
to visualize the bridge between where
you are and where you need to go the
bridge yes and
particularly the horrible stuff also to
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video I've designed
a special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there I like to think about life as one
long road trip every year of your life
is a mile marker on the road of life and
the thing about this road trip is it's a
solo Journey you started at Mile zero
and you were alone that's how you came
into this world and wherever the road of
your life leads you when you leave this
world you're going to be alone when you
leave yes you'll be surrounded by family
and friends
but when you actually pass over you are
on your own and the truth is it is a
solo Journey yes you're going to drive
parallel with some people yes you're
going to intersect with some people yep
you're going to travel in packs but you
are driving alone and look I'm not
telling you this to make you feel
isolated or unsupported that's the last
thing that I want you to feel the reason
why I'm telling you this is because I
want you to understand the power that
you have to
make these dreams part of your
day-to-day life as you pursue them I
mean maybe you've been so worried about
what everybody else is going to think
and that's what's kept you from starting
your YouTube channel or writing that
screenplay or making a career change I'm
here to tell you no one gives a about
what you do you want to know why because
everybody else is driving their own car
on their own solo journey and they're
busy trying to figure out their own life
when you realize
that the only person who is truly
judging you right now is
you when you Embrace that you're the one
in your way it can spark a fire in your
gut yes it sucks that my friend has been
telling herself for 20 years that she's
not a real writer that she's not a
respected writer that it's not that
interesting yeah that sucks to wake up
and realize that you're the one that's
been dragging yourself down but but you
want to know what sucks more spending
another 20 years never writing it so
step one you have to acknowledge the
thing that's on your list and that's in
your heart and then step two is take
responsibility for doing whatever you
can however you're capable in whatever
big or small
way to move toward it get serious about
looking ahead inad instead of looking
back looking out the window in front of
you at the road ahead and where you want
to go you can inch your way day by day
week by week month by month year by year
to creating a whole new life for
yourself everybody that struggles with
addiction does this exact same thing
tomorrow I'm not drinking that's it I
I'm done with this and then the next
morning it's the
same pattern of negative crap that
you're doing to yourself and this this
is exactly what you talk about all the
time it's not the what you need to do
it's how how do you make yourself do the
things that feel hard or scary or don't
seem like they're going to work cuz
you're resigned and you're stuck in your
patterns that was me I knew I needed to
get out of bed I knew I needed to stop
drinking I knew I needed to look for a
job I knew this wasn't Chris's fault and
I needed to stop screaming at him all
the time but I wasn't doing any of those
things I didn't know how and so this was
the moment I created the 5sec r and
again this is another I beam or t- beam
or whatever the hell beam it's called
I'm sitting in front of the television
and I am watching TV the kids are in bed
and I'm drinking uh Bourbon and I'm
probably on like my fourth Manhattan and
I'm having my nightly pep talk and I'm
going that's it tomorrow morning it's
the new me I I got to wake up I got to
do this I got to do the other thing and
all of a sudden Rich honest to goodness
I see a rocket ship launch at the end of
a commercial and I go that's it tomorrow
morning I'm launching myself out of bed
like like a rocket and that was the
beginning of the 5-second rule the high
five habit has taught me how to
truly be fulfilled and be connected to
myself to support myself and that's what
you need right now you can't rely on
anything outside of you you cannot rely
on the world fixing itself you have to
find your power inside you when you know
that you can have your own back and when
you know that you can literally move the
needle on anything through your own
attitude and your own um uh effort you
will have a sense of confidence you've
never experienced before I see Bridget
asked does the high five habit serve as
a reset for our brains yes it does in
fact it does something even more
profound than a reset for your brain
what it does Bridget is and this is a
GameChanger and I'm going to explain the
science right
now it not only hits the reset button
and breaks all of those negative habits
that are in your mind the the negative
selft talk the bashing the Judgment the
shame the all of it it hits the reset
button on that and more
importantly it programs in an entirely
new soundtrack as it relates to how you
see yourself and you want to know the
coolest part everybody you don't have to
say a darn thing
your body and your mind are designed to
do this for you after you wake up 543 21
and you get up and then I make by bed
you go high five to the heart you got a
calm nervous system now I want you to
walk into the bathroom and when you walk
into the bathroom and you stand with
yourself in front of the mirror I want
you to take a moment okay and I want you
to just be with yourself because I
guarantee you right now you have a habit
that is part of your morning routine
and that habit that you have that's part
of your morning routine is the opposite
of a high five this is the part of your
morning routine you know where you're
brushing your teeth and you basically
check out and you start to bash your
appearance or you ignore yourself or you
think about the day ahead and you
automatically think about everything
that's about to go wrong or that you
haven't done this is the part of your
morning routine that is a habit where
your mindset goes negative and so what I
want to do is I want you to create a
brand new deliberate and intentional
habit right after you brush your teeth
because you got to clean those teeth of
yours you know you cannot go out in the
world with dragon breath every day you
got to clean the teeth the second that
you put your toothbrush down now we are
going to do the high five habit and I
want you to do it right after you brush
your teeth because science tells us when
you stack a new habit with something you
already do every day it makes it much
easier for your brain to remember
remember it and for it to become part of
your subconscious routine so as you put
the toothbrush down and you stand there
I want you to take a minute and I want
you to look at yourself and look past
your body there's a human being in there
a human being that has been waiting for
you to wake up and look them in the eyes
and start showing up and supporting and
cheering and celebrating them and as you
look at yourself I want you to think
about
something who are you going to be today
for that
person how are you going to show up
today for the person you see reflected
in the
mirror and as you think about your life
and what matters to you and what your
goals are what's the game that you're
playing how we G to inch the ball down
the field
today because remember I believe that
productivity is about making progress in
something that matters to you so what is
the game you're playing today that
matters to you and how we going to inch
the ball down the field and once you've
set that intention which based on recent
research
everybody all you need is just a minute
of intentional reflection about how
you're going to show up today and who
you're going to be and based on research
it increases your productivity it
changes how you behave and it increases
the impact that you have on those PE
those folks around you when you catch
yourself
procrastinating forgive
yourself step
one the next time you catch yourself
procrastinating Step One is forgive
yourself and there's a really profound
reason
why procrastination is not about
laziness it's not about a lack of
discipline it's not something you do
because you're dumb procrastination is a
coping mechanism you just have a desire
to feel good right now and you deserve
that you have a desire to lessen the
stress in your life and you deserve to
lessen the stress in your life I get it
and this first step to forgive yourself
this comes from research from Dr pel by
the way he has been studying
procrastination for two decades may just
imagine that studying procrastination
for two that that is a dedicated person
right there and we thank you for your
service to all of us his research found
that people who forgive themselves are
less likely to procrastinate again in
fact there was a study that he did I
want to turn to the page I got the book
right here he co-authored a paper about
how students who forgave themselves for
procrastinating were less likely to
procrastinate on their next test it
sounds silly but part of the problem
that psychologists have uncovered is
that when you're somebody that
procrastinates you're really hard on
yourselves to begin with in fact being
hard on yourself is one of the major
causes of why you're so damn stressed
and so taking a moment and forgiving
yourself and you've got to actually have
a talk with yourself where you are
sitting there like oh my God two hours
just went by wow I must be really
stressed out I forgive myself for just
blowing off two hours on social media
and you know what I can spend the next
hour setting my day up tomorrow for
success or maybe you see all your bills
and you realize you haven't opened those
suckers in two
months just go wow I haven't opened my
bills in two months I must be really
nervous about this I forgive myself for
not doing that and you know what I'm
going to do I I'm I'm G to just do the
best that I can I'm G to face this head
on because the next step that you're
going to take once you forgive yourself
you got to recognize that you're doing
it why because patterns and habits
repeat unless you replace them and so
noticing that it's a pattern catching
yourself forgiving yourself that is a
way we're going to break this pattern I
am here at the Dallas Convention Center
and there are 3,000 chairs out there and
we have just run through the tech
rehearsal and I'm going to tell you a
little secret about um how I manage my
uh nerves and how I flip it into
excitement and this is something you can
steal there's always a reason why you
are doing something and when you can
find the reason or the purpose for why
you want to either give that speech or
destroy this sales uh presentation or
walk into your boss and advocate for
yourself because of the contributions
that you're making or you just want to
find the courage to stand up in a town
meeting and talk there's always a reason
why and so before you're about to do it
one of the things that you want to do is
you want to remind yourself of why this
matters to you I want to for example at
work I want to be compensated and valued
for my contributions and it's my
responsibility to make those
contributions known and so so I'm going
to be super proud of myself if and when
I say this or I want to make a
difference in my town and so I'm going
to have to start speaking up because my
voice needs to be heard I don't want to
be complaining about what's going on in
this town in my own house I want to be
advocating for what changes I'd like to
see make because I can make a difference
for me whenever I give a speech I always
say the same thing to myself I say that
yes there are 3,000 seats here but I'm
only ever talking to one person and I
believe that there is one person in this
audience
today who is here because they are meant
to be here and there is something that I
am about to say that
will change their entire life that
they're going to learn something that
might cure their anxiety or that might
help them through a very very very dark
moment to know that this is temporary
there is someone that's going to be
inspired to make a major change and I
know that in the course of the hour that
I am speaking on this stage something is
going to happen that is meant for that
person and if I trust that it allows me
to just ditch the script and show up as
my full highest Express self you know
look it might be that I trip on the
stage coming out not planned but
somebody in the audience seeing that wow
if that woman on the stage trips and she
gets back up maybe I can stumble and get
back up too look at how she just brushes
it off and she doesn't care what if I
had that I mean it could be that it
could be something really profound like
getting sober or leaving a really
abusive marriage so I remind myself of
that and I'm only ever talking to one
person and that helps me uh it helps me
to stay focused and to know that what
I'm about to do even if it makes my
stomach twist and Knots or even if I'm a
little quote nervous
about how it's going to go it helps me
stay aligned with my purpose and that's
where your power Power Alley is always
in life and that's why it's so important
for you to push yourself to express
yourself and advocate for yourself and
share your story and so steal that
idea remind yourself of why you're doing
this only talk to one person and tell
yourself that there is a person in this
room and you are meant to say something
in this room because somebody needs to
hear you say it and when you trust that
it's not about you it's about the impact
that you're about to make all anxiety
comes from childhood and it comes from
the experience of being separate in
childhood and so every single one of us
has an experience and you may not
remember it because 80% of your brain is
formed by the time you're 5 years old
but you have an experience where you as
a kid
feel distinct and separate from your
caregiver and he talks a lot about this
concept of a parental mismatch so there
are a lot of us that have parents who
are wonderful people or maybe they're
not wonderful people but you have
parents who are wonderful people but for
you emotionally just like the five love
languages there can be a mismatch in
terms of the love language you speak in
need and what your partner does that
your parent and the way that they
provide emotional support is a mismatch
and so as a kid when you don't get the
reassurance you need or when you don't
feel loved or seen or heard or accepted
you feel separate from the parent that
you're biologically hardwired and
needing to bond with which also means
you feel unsafe and so as a little kid
at some point an alarm would go off in
your body whenever you felt separate
from your parents and it could be as
innocuous as go hug your uncle and
you're like this I don't want to hug my
uncle you're like get in there um or
don't do that now I'm busy or the
snapping at you and you immediately feel
that alarm because you feel separate and
so what happens is that this alarm that
starts going off and going off and going
off in moments where you feel separate
you're not feeling the love that you
need you're not feeling connected you're
not feeling reassured it starts to go
off all the time now as you get older
and older and older I mean we've all had
the experience of walking in to see old
friends at lunch and for many of us we
feel that alarm go off they've all
arrived there they're all talking you
feel that sense of Separation that's
anxiety that's what it is it's in your
body and it is according to Dr Kennedy
it is the little you basically waving
their hand saying I need a little
reassurance right now that's all that it
is and for decades I have have
approached what has been an experience
of living with anxiety from the neck up
I mean the 5-sec rule is a neck up
approach and based on the last two years
of intense therapy that I've been in and
you know a lot of stuff that I've
recently learned from Dr Kennedy I
realize it is fundamentally a neck down
issue that attacking anxiety and these
moments where you feel separate or
scared or you feel the alarm go off in
your body if you instead of treating it
like a signal that something's wrong if
you actually treat it as a signal that
you just need a little bit of love from
yourself right now just put your hand on
your heart you can like take a towel and
kind of do this on your back rub it back
and forth and you feel like you're
hugging yourself take a deep breath tell
yourself whatever you need to hear in
that moment in order to reassure
yourself that you're going to be okay or
that whatever you know get it you know
you feel a little nervous but all those
people at that table love you it's
freaking
Bonkers how powerful of approaches is
and it's also made me realize that
wow I am so not used to giving myself
that kind of love and
reassurance no wonder I'm uncomfortable
letting other people give it to me my
definition of confidence that I want
everyone to walk away with is confidence
is the willingness to try in research
there is something called the confidence
competency Loop and what that means is
that as you try something for the first
time like I was curling my hair this
morning and I freaking burned my ear and
my daughter casually says got to learn
somehow by trying and by the way
screwing it up and burning my ear I
still am gaining a little bit of
confidence I know to hold this thing a
little bit further away from my ear Now
by gaining confidence by burning my ear
I now am going to try again and I'm
going to be a little bit better and I'm
going to gain a little bit more
confidence and then I'm going to try
again and I'm going to learn even more
and so confidence at the heart of
confidence is action it's the
willingness to try and all you need is
to know that if you try you're not going
to die you're just going to learn
something and when you learn something
it removes little bit of the insecurity
so that it makes it slightly easier to
try again and so I would follow the 60%
rule okay and I use 60% because that is
the figure that was in the HP study
about man applying for jobs when they
feel 60% qualified MH if you look at
something that you want to do or try or
apply for and you
feel whether it's 60% qualified okay I
got 60% of the stuff because the truth
is a job description everybody a dating
profile that is not requirements that's
a wish list okay if you got 60% of this
stuff freaking go for it that's rule
number one the 60% rule the other thing
is is that if you're looking at doing
something that you're scared to do maybe
it's signing up for an improv class
maybe it is ordering the podcast
equipment maybe it's signing up for
genius like you've been thinking about
it you've been thinking about it you've
thinking about it if you on a scale
you're on this teeter totter if you tip
more toward I'd really like to so about
60% right wait versus 40% I'm kind of
nervous freaking do it that's how you
build confidence because back to the
original thing that we're talking
about self-doubt grows when you engage
in negative talk to talk yourself out of
the things you want to be trying there
is so much pain Jay in talking in
yourself out of trying
things and it just makes me so sad and
frustrated to see so many of you that
are listening wasting years of your
life really feeling this desire to try
something and putting all your energy
all your energy into talking yourself
out of it what's the number one thing
that people have come up to you and said
Mel I'm so glad that you told me that
cuz I've been applying that in my
day-to-day life it's without a doubt the
5-second rule which is a brain hack that
I invented 14 years ago when anxiety
consumed me we were 800 Grand in debt
and I couldn't get out of bed so we're
talking about morning routines and
finding space for yourself and I would
literally spend an hour every morning
staring at the ceiling consumed with our
problems and anxiety and depression and
the 5sec rule is a simple tool everybody
needs to know it every kid needs to know
it you simply count backwards 5 4 3 2 1
in a moment where your hesitating or
afraid and then move just get up oh
absolutely because something happens in
your brain when you count backwards you
interrupt the patterns of worry and
procrastination and beating yourself up
and you go 5 4 3 2 1 and you require the
prefrontal cortex to pay attention which
is the part of the brain that gives you
immediate control over what you do next
there's one habit that will change your
life just one and it is do not sleep
with your phone MH because the one
decision everybody makes that kills your
productivity kills your focus tanks your
mental health is before you get yourself
right you grab your phone and check in
with the world and that means you gave
your most important commodity your time
and your attention to things that don't
matter what should you do with that 10
minutes do you think use a 5 second rule
54 3 21 get out of bed do not lay there
like a human pot roast marinating in
fear staring at the ceiling get out of
bed second thing I want you to do make
your bed wait don't hit snooze though
can you hit no you shouldn't and there's
a there's actually a neurological reason
why so people who hit the snooze button
based on the research when you drift
back into sleep it triggers your brain
to go into a sleep cycle that typically
lasts between 75 and 90 minutes and when
the alarm goes back off five minutes
five minutes you're in what they call a
state of sleep inertia oh so you're all
oh it impacts your productivity hours
okay so don't do that okay then make
your bed make your bed because it is a
way to keep a small promise to yourself
it's also a way to have a nice place to
come back to like a gift tonight it's a
simple way to build a little discipline
the third thing I want you to do when
you go to the bathroom is I want you to
look in the mirror and I want you to add
an high five in the mirror to your
morning routine a high five to yourself
yes okay there's a reason why okay we
did this massive study 50% of men and
women cannot look at themselves in the
mirror in the morning and the rest of us
glance at ourselves in the mirror and
focus on what we hate if you physically
raise your hand without saying a word
and you raise your hand to the mirror
something crazy happens a lifetime of
positive neurological programming that
has been attached to the act of giving a
high five to other people gets aimed
back at you wow the next thing I want
you to do is simply take five minutes
the remaining five minutes that you have
and do some kind of mindset practice and
as the close of the practice before you
look at your phone mhm I want you to
decide what is one thing that matters to
me today that I'm going to make progress
on that's it how do you stop
procrastinating oh simple just nail
yourself to a chair that's what you do
you tell yourself no booze until you get
it done that works no it doesn't the
reason why these things don't work is
because most of us don't even understand
what procrastination is I know I
certainly didn't the reason why you
procrastinate is not why you think
procrastination has nothing to do with
work
procrastination is a stress reliever
that's right it's a tool that you use to
give yourself relief from stress that
you feel and the stress that you may be
feeling right now might be stressed
about money you might be stressed about
your health maybe you're stressed about
something going on at work or about a
relationship that you're in and the way
that this relates to procrastination is
you're stressed out you got work you
know you need to do but instead of doing
it you go online or you watch the
highlights of last night's game or you
waste an hour looking at Facebook and
when you do that when you avoid work
makes you feel good but just for a
minute see this is where we get
procrastination all wrong a lot of
people think proc procastination is
about willpower it means that you're
lazy has nothing to do with that it's
all about your stress that's why your
work ethic or discipline that's not
that's not going to solve this either
the key to stopping procrastination
number one is understanding what it is
it's a way that you deal with stress and
number two it's about 5c decisions that
stop the cycle of procrastinating
because when you change your decisions
you're going to change everything and
here's how you're going to use the
5-second rule to do
it when you catch yourself
procrastinating or you feel yourself
starting to avoid what you need to do
use the rule 54321 activate your
prefrontal cortex and then acknowledge
acknowledge that you feel stressed out
that's the first piece then you're going
to use the 5-second rule to just get
started that's it for 5 minutes that's
all I'm asking force yourself I'm
stressed out I get it but I'm going to
work for for 5 minutes 54 3 2 1 sit down
and get started after you've worked for
5 minutes give yourself a break watch
all the cat videos you want I don't
really
care the point here is that this is a
way that you can use the 5-second rule
in combination with research about
beating procrastination that puts you in
control of your decisions use the alarm
on your phone seriously this is this is
a genius back put the alarm on your
phone to use to help you be your future
self it's like a it's like a reminder
from the Future Okay cake stun get up go
check on it no seriously so every single
smartphone has the ability to set an
alarm and on the alarm when you go to
set the time there's a there's a
label right now it says alarm you can
literally change the label to help you
remember anything and here's what's
super cool about a simple alarm in your
phone research has found that twice as
many people who received quit smoking
messages quit smoking over a six-month
period so these little systems like
setting an alarm in your phone whether
you're reminding yourself to take the
vitamins that you want to be taking or
you're reminding yourself to get outside
for the run or you're reminding yourself
to spend 30 minutes working on a project
that you wanted to get done they're
going to make you based on the research
twice as successful twice more likely
this simple stuff works and it's not
that hard let's I it's not that hard
right not that hard to put a Post-It
note on the mirror not that hard to set
an alarm in your phone not that hard to
set the water bottle out but you got to
do it okay simple systems work because
your life is complicated enough and if
you can put that posit note up you are
setting yourself up for Success I'm
telling you it's true we are in too much
of a cancel culture we ghost people we
label people and toss them to the side
and I believe that every human being is
capable of changing and I also believe
that if you want people to become better
whether that's better in terms of their
mental health or better in terms of
their habits or addictions or beliefs or
whatever it may be you have to create
room for people to change and by
labeling somebody as toxic and then just
tossing them out the
window you are not identifying the
behavior that doesn't work for
you and when you start to go the
behavior of s of you giving me the
silent
treatment is toxic
behavior and this is what my boundary is
with it work on your
own because the secret to a happy
relationship is you being happy mhm and
the person that you're with being a
happy person that's like like somebody
once said to me you want to know the
secret to a happy marriage Mel I said
what is it he said marry somebody who's
happy working on your own happiness
because if you're not a happy
person the easiest person to attack is
your intimate partner it's the person
you love the most correct like think
about when you're a kid you have to hold
your together at school you have to like
look good for your friends you have to
like stick it out at that job that you
had as a teenager that you couldn't
stand but when you come home you can you
snap at your mom you might be rude to
your dad you ignore your brothers and
sisters you let it all hang out with
them and we do that that with our
intimate partners and so if you're not
taking care of your own happiness you're
going to vomit your baggage at the
person who loves you most so that's it
what you're dealing with when you have
impostor syndrome is you're dealing with
a lack of
selfworth you
literally kind of see all the things
working out but you've got this like
annoying voice in your head that's
saying you don't deserve this this is
luck how many of you have that story
this is luck this is going to run out
this isn't due to me yeah we got to
literally destroy that voice that is
from your past and part of the reason
why you have that V that voice by the
way is because of racism it's because of
discrimination it's because of childhood
trauma it's because of uh various
experiences that you've had where either
your experience is growing up or Society
at large has made you feel either
overtly or in in a really like gross and
sort of Sly way like you don't belong
and so it is critical for you to start
to punch that voice literally out of
your head and I'm going to give you some
steps to do it okay um the second thing
that's really important is that in
addition to stopping down that voice
because it's not your
voice that is somebody else's voice that
your brain listened to and then started
repeating and the thing about your brain
is that your brain is this really cool
computer that learns
patterns and what I want you to
understand is that patterns
repeat unless you break and replace them
and if you have a pattern of thinking
like what Heidi has that says you're not
worthy you don't deserve this luck is
going to run out at some point that you
know what's going to hit the fan again
brace don't count on anything like you
didn't earn this if you got that pattern
running in your head that is a broken
pattern you're not broken that pattern
of thinking is broken and so the Line in
the Sand that I want to draw starting
today is you're not allowed to listen to
that garbage anymore we are going to go
on a mission together to notice whenever
it comes up oh interesting there it is
there's that pattern it's spinning just
like a load of laundry right up there
and I'm going to teach you once you
recognize that pattern you're going to
use this thing that I created called the
5-sec rule you're going to count
backwards 5 4 3 2 1 because that shuts
that down and counting backwards let's
all do it together here we go 5 4 3 2 1
now notice when you counted did you feel
a little pressure right here yeah that
was me hypnotizing you no I'm just
kidding um what you were feeling
is by counting backwards it's a little
brain Hack That interrupts all the
garbage that's here in the interior part
of your brain this is where impostor
syndrome lives everybody this is where
anxiety is this is where self-doubt is
this is where self-criticism is this is
where it's all stored when you notice oh
there's that voice again and you count
backwards 5 43 2 1 you shut it down and
then you awaken this part of your brain
this is the part of the brain that you
used when you were taking the SATs this
is the part of the brain that you used
when you applied for that job when you
speak up in that meeting when you tell
somebody no you cannot borrow my dress
tonight no when you have boundaries
right this is the part of the brain that
gives you immediate control over what
you think and do next how do I use this
energy exchange and my intuition to spot
the things that are draining me dry and
to let them go push them off the
branches get them out of my life thank
them for their purpose and their service
but then get out of here because you
need to make room for something new and
better and energizing doesn't that sound
good yeah you better believe it sounds
good so let's do it and one of the
reasons why I want you to really focus
on energy is because your energy doesn't
lie I mean just for a second with me
just take a
second whether you're out there walking
the dog or you're driving around in your
car or you're working from home or
you're busy doing a bunch of stuff I
want you to just stop for a
second and I want you to assess right
now what's your energy level think about
a fuel gauge in a car empty to full
empty in a human being means you feel
depleted you feel burnt out you feel
checked out you feel like your whole
life is basically pouring energy into
everything else full in a human being
basically means that you're energized
you're excited you feel like the things
that you're pouring yourself into your
habits your routine the people you're
surrounded with the projects you're
working on it may be difficult but it's
bringing energy back into your life
too your energy never
lies we are energetic human beings and I
know that sounds woo woo we can get into
the Neuroscience on that on a totally
different episode but let me prove it to
you have you ever walked into say a
coffee shop and the person that is
behind the counter is having the world's
worst day they are super grumpy it
doesn't matter how big your smile is it
doesn't matter how nice you are they are
like that
energy actually impacts you just like
your positive energy can impact somebody
else energy is contagious Seinfeld
famously joked that that um the person
in the coffin isn't scared it's the
person who has to speak about the person
in the coffin who is the fear of public
speaking is the number one fear that
people have and I don't even mean
necessarily talking on a stage like I do
for a living I'm talking about the fear
of speaking in public sharing your ideas
at work expressing what you need to
other people having hard conversations
with friends and family talking at a
meeting at school
uh pushing back on something uh with a
doctor like just being able to express
yourself and the reason why this is such
a huge fear for people is because it is
a moment of intense
vulnerability the second that you go to
speak at work what happens everybody
turns and all eyes are on you and
suddenly you feel like there's a
spotlight on you and you get really
worried about being
judged uh same thing happens when you
have to speak in class right right when
you got called on in class most people
get a little nervous a lot of people
hated that moment in elementary school
when you had to read out loud that's a
moment of public speaking and we are so
afraid in that moment when the spotlight
is on us and I've shared in a number of
episodes that I used to be terrified of
public speaking I would turn bright red
when I got called on as a little kid uh
in law school I would start coughing
attacks or I would leave the room uh as
a young uh lawyer I would wear a scarf
because I'd get these neck rashes as I
was talking to the judge and to the
prosecutor in a small uh courtroom and I
just figured I would be the kind of
person that always had a bright red face
always had an awful case of hives on my
chest always felt my tongue going dry
and I hated it I hated it hated it hated
it I want fear to stop holding you back
I want you to trust fall into your life
I want you to take that first step and
climb the staircase to the things that
you want in your life and there are too
many places where fear holds you back
and keeps you silent and has you
questioning yourself and so that was me
too and I just chipped away at this and
I am so glad that I did because I just
can't even
imagine
how much I would yearn for what I'm
doing now without even realizing it but
the first step is admitting that there
are fears that are holding you back and
so we're going to use public speaking
because it's the number one fear for
everybody this is an exercise called
looking for hearts and this is how you
play it every single day when you wake
up you are going to go on a scavenger
hunt in your day-to-day life and you are
going to try to find a naturally
occurring heart shape somewhere in the
world it could be a cloud that's shaped
like a heart you could look at your
coffee and see that the foam on top has
made the shape of a heart you might get
out of your car and you'll see a stain
on the floor or a leaf that's the shape
of a heart I constantly constantly see
rocks I see heart shapes in the top of
mountain ranges I see the shape of
Hearts uh in brick buildings all the
time in terms of the different colors of
bricks and here's what's interesting
about
this what you'll realize is that there
are probably 10,000 heart shapes that
are around you in your day-to-day life
the stain on the carpet the spot on your
dog's back the tear in a pair of pants
the shape of a leaf they're everywhere
they're absolutely everywhere and right
now you walk right by them why well
because they're not important to you you
have not told the bouncer of your brain
to let the hearts in to the nightclub so
you are walking right past all these
things and they are actively being
blocked out it is not in your your
conscious mind the second you start
playing this game find a heart you will
experience something amazing you will
experience your brain going to work for
you and so here's how I want you to play
this because I do want you to play this
every single day this is truly not a
game about finding Hearts this is about
training your mind this is a game where
you are telling your mind I am the
freaking boss b of the mind I pay your
salary you are going to do what I tell
you to do you are going to find me a
heart and if you want to get paid you
are going to find me a heart that is
your job today find me a heart so get
intentional about that and then I want
you to go through your life and just let
a heart shape in and when you see it
here's what I want you to do and if
you're really analytical you're going to
think this is is the cheesiest damn
thing you've ever heard but I want you
to do this because there's Neuroscience
involved when you see that heart I want
you to pause and I want you to really
stare at it for a minute you can take a
photo of it if it's a rock you can pick
it up or a leaf and take it with you
because I want you to reward your brain
for being flexible and for trying to
help you I want you to take that moment
for real as cheesy this sounds the foam
on the top of your coffee the shadow on
the floor I want you to take a minute
and really savor it and literally just
go
holy there it is that's pretty cool
yesterday I walked right past this and I
didn't even see it thank you mind wow
you you you just changed in real time
you just let something in that I asked
you to let that in and if you really
want to supersize this if you're
somebody that's really struggling with a
sense of self-worth or hope or really
believing that you can turn things
around I want
you to look at that and tell yourself
that that was placed there for you to
find that this was placed there because
you needed to see evidence that it is in
fact possible to change the way you
think it is in fact possible to tell
your mind what you want to see more
evidence of and for your mind to work
for you there is no reason not to be
kind to other people there is no reason
not to ask for help in a polite manner
because the people that you're asking
for help from almost never responsible
for the thing that's not working and the
person that's emailing you at work who's
all frustrated because the Q4 numbers
and the and the client this and the like
you're not responsible for the stuff
that's stressing them
out and so here's what I did in that
moment because a couple things happened
in that story number one that woman's
[__] behavior and entitlement it's
like
contagious and when somebody's yelling
at you whether it's an email or you're
separated by the front desk at the hotel
that you're working at it's still like
gets all over you I think about the
visual almost like if you've ever walked
your dog and they jump into like muddy
water or they roll in the mud or heaven
forbid you're walking on the beach and
there's a big nasty rotting fish on the
beach and your dog runs right up to it
before you can get to the dog and now
your dog is rolling all in it and it's
like and then they run over to you and
what is a wet dirty dog always do when
that dog gets up to you they shake and
when they Shake all of that negative
nasty muddy fish blah blah blah blah
blah it just hits you and when somebody
is in a positive or a nasty mood it's
like a muddy dog shaking and that energy
gets all over you and so it's critical
in these
moments that you protect your energy and
for me I normally speak up when I see
this kind of thing because normally I
have really great energy and I'm not
going to let somebody get away with that
but the truth is I was really tired I
had just flown across country and we
were in town to do something that was
weighing on my mind and I just didn't
want to get into a fight with somebody
who clearly had an ax to grind with
absolutely anybody and I'm not going to
change this person anyway and so what I
do in those moments when I start seeing
that muddy dog shake or that high
ponytail start flap in her mouth and and
being
rude is number one I take take a deep
breath that's it I just take a deep
breath and there's a breath technique
that you can use called 478 I don't
remember who came up with this I'm sure
some we'll put it in the show notes but
you breathe in for 4
seconds hold it for
seven then out for
eight
and I read somewhere that the eight part
is the most important because when you
breathe out for longer than you breathed
in it sends a signal to your nervous
system that it's okay to relax what
we're talking about is whether or not
you're hiding in plain sight
now the reason why I want to talk to you
about whether or not you're hiding in
plain sight is because say if you're not
the real you the people who are looking
for you can't find you I'm going to say
that again if you're not living your
life if you're not showing up at work if
you're not going through the process of
dating and being the real
you the people who are looking for you
can't find
you and the secret to life and this is
so hard to ass is to just be yourself
that's the
secret there's only one you there's only
ever going to be one you there's never
going to be another you and the way you
make your mark in this world the way
that you learn how to believe in
yourself the way that you discover the
people that you're supposed to surround
yourself with the job that you or career
path that you're supposed to have is by
being the real you and it's terrifying I
get it I was a chameleon for a very long
time and when I say long time I mean
like the first 40 some years of my life
and what does it mean to be a chameleon
being a chameleon means that you adapt
to your surroundings and you blend in
that you're scared to let the real you
be seen I mean think about a chameleon
they hide in plain sight and so if you
are in a
relationship like I used to be I used to
be in relationships and I wasn't even
present I was hiding in plain sight I
was a chameleon if uh you were somebody
that I was dating and you liked the
Grateful Dead guess what I liked I liked
the Grateful Dead if you like to eat
pizza guess what I liked I like to eat
pizza if you like to sit around and
watch uh baseball for three and a half
hours guess what I like to do not really
but guess what I would do and pretend
that I would like to you because I was
so convinced that I was not a good
person that I was not likable I was
terrified of disappointing anybody and
it may be hard to believe that because
you see me now but this is how I live my
life and the problem with being a
chameleon and give me a thumbs up if you
can relate to this and here's another
challenge I have for you let's come out
of hiding right now tell me confess to
yourself where is it in your life that
you're hiding in plain sight right now
that the real you isn't present is it at
work
do you have ideas at work and you just
show up and go through the motions and
you don't put yourself or your best work
out there are you hiding in plain sight
because you're at a job that you can't
stand are you hiding in plain sight
because you're in a relationship and you
know that the person that you're with
has all of the power in your the
relationship you're scared of upsetting
him or her and so you stay quiet or you
don't make the requests that you need to
to make are you hiding inside a body
that's not truly who you are that you're
hiding in plain sight and underneath the
body that you're in whether you're way
unhealthy too skinny or you're
overweight and you know that that's not
the real you but you're hiding in plain
sight because you're scared to be seen
this is a major issue for a lot of us
and when you think about the areas in
your life where you are hiding in plain
sight and please Tracy if you see where
people are giving me examples or Audrey
let me hear some examples work relation
relationships and school a lot school a
lot I bet in school you maybe aren't
taking classes or majoring and what you
really care about maybe you're not um
asking questions because you're afraid
to look stupid relationships this is
huge and the reason why it's huge in
relationships and where so many of you
are hiding in plain sight is that you're
afraid of getting rejected you're afraid
of disappointing somebody you're afraid
of rocking the boat and so you don't you
just blend in like a chameleon does the
single biggest obstacle to you
experiencing more joy in your life is
your own inner critic first you have to
identify that you're doing it and you
see that with your kids and just like
the associates were seeing it with the
guests that were coming in right you can
see it in a friend when they're
criticizing yourself you have to
identify it in yourself and so it's
almost like it's a feeling am I holding
myself back am I coming up with an
excuse am I speaking to myself the way
that a friend Tot so you got to identify
it second you got to interrupt it you
have to interrupt it and a quick way
that you can do it is give it a name oo
wow yes well just think of a name yeah
that you could call that nasty negative
part of your and that girl is she's
creeping up or know Gina Gina for me
Gina yeah so when Gina appears what do I
say to Gina shut up
Gina yeah shut up Gina you're not you're
not going to the painting class wow shut
up I bet when you thought about starting
your book club yeah that inner critic
was there oh yeah and the thing is
imposter syndrome right well that is
kind of part of it part of it they're
friends when you feel small when you
feel yourself shrinking when you feel
yourself pulling back or saying I
couldn't do that oh the excuses that you
come up with they may be legitimate
obstacles yeah but you got a brain and
you can solve problems and when you tell
Gina shut up yeah we're starting this
book club yeah you now aim your thinking
at what you want instead of spending
your time listening to Gina tell you
what you can't do if you have big goals
you better stand in front of that mirror
and high-five yourself every day every
single step of the way stop looking
around and waiting for everybody else to
do it start giving it to yourself and
you will be shocked at how much more
quickly things start to happen at how
much more joy you experience along the
way at how much more present you are
yeah it's wild and this isn't about like
pumping yourself up to think you're like
the best person on the planet this is
like the
Baseline this is literally being like
you know what you're going to have an
okay day let's go do this mhm you know
what I see you I know this is hard keep
going I I know you're nervous to have
this hard conversation with this person
I believe you can do it let's go yeah
like it's just one little boost along
the way you know if you think about the
things that go
viral it's little kids in front of a
mirror with their parents getting them
to talk themselves yeah
correct we all know that's how we're
supposed to feel mhm but we feel weird
and cheesy practicing it you kidding me
right the other thing that goes viral
all these teachers that are high-fiving
and fist bumping kids with the
handshakes as they go in and the mirror
one with the I am that just kind of went
viral why do we all love that because we
know each one of those kids just felt
seen and felt good and felt motivated
walking into that classroom mhm start
your day that way I literally fail over
and over and over again I lose my way a
million times before I find myself and
even when I find myself I eventually
feel lost again and go looking for
myself again constantly seeking
constantly growing constantly failing
and so I start this life coaching
business I love it it goes incredibly
incredibly well um this would have been
like 2002 to like 2 I don't know I'm
guessing here six maybe and um what ends
up happening is a friend of mine emails
me forwards an email to me and when you
look at the chain of the for
the form when you look at the chain of
the forward what you see at the bottom
is there's somebody at Inc magazine
looking to write an article about life
coaches and I immediately scan the thing
and it's a month old the deadline is
passed I have none of the credentials
they're looking for I have none of the
types of clients they're looking
for and
I start to go like we always do down the
list of reasons why I should not respond
like we're always arguing against
ourselves always holding ourselves back
and I'm I immediately say wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute um what
would somebody who's more successful
than me do I'm like they apply right so
I take a sip of wine I start typing like
crazy and I just free form this
hilarious response back a month late
with none other credentials da da da da
d da she writes back the next day and
says I was about to turn the article in
what if I come to Boston next week and T
Trail you wow so she comes she follows
me around for a day she ends up
publishing an article and I'm like oh
yes cuz oh that's right cuz the article
uh released in 2005 and I'm like this is
going to be amazing the timing of this
article is fabulous this article is
going to print rich and I am going to
have an avalanche of clients it's going
to be awesome the article prints
crickets not a single client not a
single inbound email not a nothing
nothing so uh I forget about it I'm out
to dinner one night my phone's ringing
it's a New York number like who the heck
is calling me from New York I pick up
the phone and is this Mel Robbins yeah
this is Mel Robbins hey this is Mary
Duffy from CNBC mik oh hi Mary Duffy how
are you having no idea who she is she's
like well I saw the article in Inc
magazine and we'd like to fly you down
and talk to you so literally a week
later I find myself on a plane down to
New York drive over to New Jersey walk
into the offices I sit down and I in a
meeting with the executives at C
CNBC and they're in a development
meeting oh my God coaching is hot we
think you're amazing we want to do a
show we want to stick it between Kramer
and Donnie Deutsch was on at the time
the big idea and we'd like you to do D D
D D D I walk out of there with a
freaking development deal oh my God
you're the kind of person just like me
that every single year you write down
the things that you want in your life
and I would imagine that as each year
rolls on and the new list gets written
you move the thing that you didn't work
on this year to the list that you do for
the next year and on and on and on I
mean how many years have you been
thinking about writing a book or
changing your job or changing where you
live or healing some aspect of your past
or finding love or learning how to love
yourself or starting that business these
things that you hold in your heart they
are meant to be out in the world and
today I'm on a mission to get you to
stop waiting stop waiting for the
perfect time stop waiting to feel ready
stop waiting for the money stop waiting
for permission stop waiting to feel like
somebody's going to care about this the
only person that needs to care enough is
you because today is the day that you're
going to pick up the pen you're going to
start the research you're going to
commit to taking action why because
that's what you're meant to do with your
life you're meant to create a bigger
vision for yourself there was a research
study done about NBA team so we got
sports fans here check this out so NBA
teams they did this study where they
wanted to know are there any like
patterns that you could trace back if
you took the championship teams and then
Trace back all the way back to the
preseason are there defined patterns
that are consistent with the
championship teams that are not present
with the teams that perform the worst
and sure enough There Were You can
predict who is going to be in the
Championships rounds of the NBA by a
simple pattern in the preseason and you
want to know what it is the teams that
go on to win have the most number of
high-fives backpacks fist bumps and
gestures of enouragement in the
preseason why would that make a
difference I'll tell you why it makes a
difference because those high fives just
like you high five a runner every step
of a marathon to encourage them to move
forward they build trust they transfer
energy they say I believe in you they
build partnership and I'm here to tell
you life is
hard you need to build a partnership
with yourself when you stand with
yourself every single morning with a
calm and cool nervous system grounded in
your body and you look at yourself in
the mirror with compassion and
forgiveness and love and understanding
and support and you decide what game
you're going to play today and who
you're going to be and how you're going
to show up and you raise your hand and
you seal that with encouragement support
and
celebration you will be
unstoppable because you will know the
secret to life and that is never giving
up on the person who is staring back at
you in the mirror and making sure that
no matter what happens the one person
who back you've always got is the one
that's always going to be with you and
you've got an opportunity every single
morning to start your day by taking care
of that person instead of criticizing
and ignoring them and if you're serious
about changing your life if you're
serious about feeling more fulfilled if
you're serious about enjoying your life
and being content and
feeling like you're in control no matter
what's going to happen that you have the
ability to survive this you have the
ability to grow for this you have the
ability to take this opportunity and
make it something even bigger part of
the reason why overwhelm is so
debilitating is because when you're
overwhelmed your focus is scattered
across absolutely everything and you're
thinking about your family and your
health and the news and the this and the
that and the presentation and the emails
you didn't do and D D D D D D D D D D D
D and at the end of the day each and
every one of those things is not really
that important there's probably can we
agree one two or three things a day that
really matter that really need your
attention and the reason why we get so
freaking
overwhelmed with life is we allow our
attention to get scattered and to get
pulled in a bazillion different
directions and the
solution to feeling more in control and
to literally dealing with overwhelm
which is just an overwhelming amount of
things that really most of which are not
that all important to you but they're
just distracting you which then pulls
your attention away from what really
matters you see I'd rather have you do
two or three things a day that really
matter to you and let the rest just kind
of fall where they fall right and so the
surprisingly simple way to deal with
overwhelm is to pick one thing that
you're going to focus on every day for
you like no matter what you're going to
do this thing you're going to add a
little structure you're going to add
something that you're committing to as a
way to laser your focus on something
that's in your control it's absolutely
awesome how this works so I'm going to
give you an example when my husband
first got diagnosed with depression he
became very
overwhelmed and what I noticed is that
he decided to take this online fitness
challenge that's a little bit more than
I'm telling you that you should do but
he did this Fitness mental toughness
challenge told 75 hard and even though
it was a pain and even though it was
hard having this challenge to focus on
as something he had chosen that he was
going to commit to every day gave his
life a simple structure that had a lot
of things that were distracting him fall
to the Wayside same thing happened with
our daughter she became very overwhelmed
after she graduated from college did not
know what she wanted to do she was in a
really unhealthy place and committing to
a simple set of new healthy habits that
really were things she could control and
committing to doing it for 3 months it
gave her this real discipline around
focusing on what mattered to her and the
overwhelm started to disappear because
when you create a simple structure for
yourself and you say you know what I'm
going to do this week
no matter what this week I'm just going
to get up when the alarm rings and I am
going to move my body for 30 minutes and
that is the simple structure I am going
to put in place for me and the reason
why simple structures like this are so
important is because in a sea of this
which is what overwhelm is like all this
stuff you're like nope there is one
thing that I am going to do for myself
today and that is the thing that I am
going to focus on in life to make people
feel welcome super important to invite
people especially other women to have a
seat at the table and one of the things
that I've learned and then I'm going to
catch you all up on where we're at okay
one of the things I've learned is that
you know it's there's so much success to
go
around have you wrapped your brain
around the fact that there are what 8
billion people on this planet there is
so much success to go around there's so
much
happiness there's a tremendous amount of
money to make there's a ton of people to
date and when you focus on the fact that
there is Limitless possibilities for you
you're not in competition with anybody
in this
room and the louder you cheer for other
people the more you invite people
in the more you will be invited in and
the more cheering there will be for
you it is incredible when you can f flip
your mind from being jealous and
competitive and small-minded like if
she's getting that it means I don't oh
no no no no no if you see somebody
getting something that you want it's
evidence that you can have it too you're
just going to get it and have it in your
own way and so you want to make it a
habit to cheer for and celebrate all the
all the women everybody you see around
you because their success means you can
have it too and trust me if you are a
talented hardworking kind
person a company will make room for you
they will find another job doing that
same thing and so you focus on you you
focus on being the best you and I
promise you all the other people around
you that are having those things that
you want that's evidence you can have it
too I like to think of other people as a
light on the path I'm walking down
they're shining a light that helps me
walk in the direction of what I want
every single day when you wake up you
can find five minutes or 10 minutes or
15 minutes to move from thinking about
what you want to taking action on what
you want picking up the pen writing a
sentence sending an email doing the
research taking a class all of these
actions are how you move towards what
you want while you're still in the life
that you have that's how you do it and
the other thing that you're going to
have to pay attention to is energy
because just like you are wasting
precious time on that doesn't really
matter to you you are also wasting your
precious energy spending time with
people who are draining it from you who
are not giving it back to you and so
every single day when you wake up I want
you to pay attention to where you're
putting your time and where you're
putting your energy and I want you to
find five measly minutes
to start working on what you want in the
physical world instead of keeping it a
secret in your heart and in your mind
one of the high five habits is what I
call giving your heart a high five and
this in many ways I think is just as
profound as high-fiving your reflection
and just the depth of research that goes
into explaining why it has such a
profound impact in terms of how you
relate to yourself
but high-fiving your heart is putting
your hands kind of right on your heart
one on top of the other CH of the other
and saying I'm okay I'm safe I'm loved
and I started doing this uh when the
pandemic hit and I started to wake up to
a wave of
anxiety and one of the things that we
learned in writing this book is that the
first thing that you need to be able to
do before your brain can even engage in
new patterns of thinking is to settle
your nervous system so you know we wrote
a bunch about the Vegas nerve but when
you put your hands over your heart first
thing in the morning and give your heart
a high five and say I'm okay I'm safe
I'm love first of all it's true because
if you can say those words you're okay
you're safe you're loved but secondly it
tones What's called the Vegas nerve
which I know you talk about on the show
that that is the secret to switching
between your parasympathetic and your
sympathetic nervous system so if you're
somebody like me who has lived your life
on edge if you grew up in a cha chaotic
household if you've experienced trauma
if you constantly feel like you're
waiting for the other shoe to drop if
you wake up and the first thought is
I've done something wrong someone's mad
at me I want you to try this other
high-f five habit by high-fiving your
heart you can say it 15 times if you
have to I'm okay I'm safe I'm loved it
will soothe your nervous system and
settle it because you cannot have new
thoughts or learn new Behavior if your
nervous system is on edge or on hyper
alert intermittent fasting is a health
protocol whereby you focus on periods of
time where you're eating and periods of
time where you are not eating the
purpose of intermittent fasting is to
use periods of time where you are not
eating to help you switch between the
two different energy sources in your
body we learned all about this in part
one from Dr Mindy you have an energy
source that is all about sugar and
calories and energy that happens when
you eat and then you have a second
energy source that only turns on after
an hour period of not eating anything
and Dr Mindy calls that your fat burning
energy source and so what we learned is
that you are designed to switch between
these two cycles kind of like how you
have cycles of sleeping and cycles of
being awake you have a circadium rhythm
cycle cycle if you're a woman you have a
menstrual cycle the human body runs on
cycles and rhythms and your eating is no
different and fasting is a way for you
to be very intentional not about what
you eat and that's why this is not a
diet diets focus on what you eat fasting
is a protocol that focuses on when
you're eating for maximum health benefit
when you stand before yourself in front
of a
mirror and you look at
yourself you drag with you your entire
past standing between you and the person
you see reflected is everything that's
been done to
you it's all of the abuse and the trauma
and the mistakes and the disappointment
and the
heartache and so many of you take all
the stuff the bad stuff that's happened
to you or in your life and you use that
as evidence to say I'm a failure I'm not
worthy I don't deserve it see all this
evidence that person I see is not not
somebody who deserves a high five
because of what's happened to them or
maybe like the rest of us you've done
things in your past that you deeply
regret you were doing things because you
were trying to survive and you haven't
forgiven yourself and so you stand there
every morning and subconsciously what's
there is is is
judgment and so if you're
resisting raising your hand and
celebrating yourself just for standing
there and just for being there and just
for showing up for another day despite
all the stuff that's
happened the resistance is the
problem because until you forgive
yourself until you start to look
yourself in the eye and say because of
all this stuff I deserve a high five
I've survived this because of everything
that has happened to me and because I
still show up and try a little harder I
deserve support I deserve celebration
and I need need it I need
it it's so obvious and yet none of us do
this we stand in judgment you think
because you got fired or your last
business failed you are a failure and
that's why you won't cheer for yourself
right now what are you dealing with just
trying to be there for my husband for my
kids and other people and you're not
there for you
though so is it more overwhelming the
way that you think or overwhelming
because you have so much going on and
you just physically can't get to all of
it physically can't get to all of it
okay one thing that I want you to do and
this is going to sound really
stupid but do you sleep with your phone
yes I do okay I us just have it right by
me I want you to stop doing that okay
okay okay and here's why your phone is
distracting you from the things that are
important and your what's on your phone
the number of emails the text people are
sending you the news that's really scary
if you have that sucker next to your bed
do you wake up in the morning and then
lie in bed and look at it it's using my
first thing like thank you Lord I'm
awake in the phone and then the phone
and when you lay there and you look at
what's on the phone how does it make you
feel emotionally tired before I get out
of the bed yes and does it start to make
you feel overwhelmed about everything
you need to do yes okay what I want you
to do instead is I want you to put the
phone like in your closet or in your
kitchen or in your bathroom plug it in
leave the ringer on cuz if your kids
need to reach you they can call you not
going to text you tell work if you need
to reach me at 2:00 in the morning don't
send me an email don't send me a text
call me okay and then I want you to go
to bed I want you to wake up you're
going to thank the Lord that you woke up
you're going to think about one thing
that you're really grateful for to
settle yourself okay and then you're
going to get up okay you're going to get
up and then I want you to go out in your
kitchen before the madness happens with
the kids in school and it's back to
school and it's overwhelming isn't it
and I want you to take five minutes
that's it five minutes to just sit and
think about what you need for you today
just one thing okay just one thing are
you going to call your mother today are
you going to um read a book for 20
minutes today are you going to go for a
walk at lunch today what's one thing
you're going to do for you and then let
the rest of the day unfold you can then
look at your phone and get overwhelmed
but I want you to at least start a tiny
little self-care okay practice in the
morning okay if you like to pray when
you get out of bed don't pray in bed you
can thank God for the fact that you got
up but get out of bed okay go into the
kitchen do your morning prayers think
about one thing for you okay then let
the rest of the world in okay okay okay
I want you to just crack open crack open
a little bit for you and then it'll
start to expand you can make it 10
minutes you can make it 15 minutes but
if you win the battle in the morning so
that you can get out of debt bed without
feeling tired and overwhelmed we can
start to spread that feeling through the
rest of your day once you make that
first cold
call you're likely to keep going once
you start writing that first sentence on
this chapter you're going to keep
writing once you hit record on that
video on the video you're going to keep
going once you fill out the first name
last name line on the application you
need to fill out you're going to keep
going once you pull up your resume
template and you start
writing you're going to keep going
because the problem isn't your ability
to do what you need to do the problem is
you've been trapped in this stress and
Trauma and nervous system triggered
vicious procrastination cycle and look I
know this sounds like
really oh my God Mel come on I I I I was
listening to this because I want to be
more productive I want to make more
money I want to get more [__] done I
want to have more life balance now
you're telling me productivity it's
about forgiving myself it's about
calling forth the future me why would I
want to try that I told you
procrastination was not about
productivity and I also told you the
thing that triggers it was going to
surprise you and that's why this topic
is so
important I say every day that it is
never too late to wake up and be the
person you want to be and you deserve
that and here's the truth on how you do
that you have to act like you believe in
yourself before you believe in
yourself I'm going to say that again you
want to learn how to stop doubting
yourself you want to learn how to
believe in yourself again you want to
learn how to not be so afraid or full of
Doubt or full of perfectionism which by
the way is something you learned in
order to cope with crap that was going
on in childhood perfectionism everybody
is what you do in order to protect
yourself from rejection there's a huge
huge connection between your desire to
be perfect procrastinating and the fear
of rejection and so using these tools
you not only are going to break the
pattern of
procrastination you have a road map for
the actions that take you to the Future
you because again you have to act like
you believe in yourself before you do
believe in yourself so let me just make
this super super detailed for you bidy
when you wake up tomorrow morning and
you sit down in that chair and you walk
through these simple steps that I have
just taught you based on the
research when you start
drawing you are acting like you believe
in
yourself and notice you started drawing
before you did believe in
yourself that's why this is so
powerful when you see yourself
acknowledging that you're
procrastinating and labeling the stress
and forgiving yourself for getting
triggered by it and then
54321 doing it anyway because you're the
kind of person that picks up the phone
or picks up the pen or walks out the
door or says that thing or does that
thing and you keep doing that
consistently you know what's going to
happen you're not only going to get the
results that you want you're going to
believe in yourself because you're going
to see yourself doing the work to get
the results that you want it begins with
the action what has been profound in my
marriage is that at the heart of all
mental health issues for me at the heart
of all your interpersonal issues with
anybody else is your own
inability to handle uncomfortable
feelings that's it that's it and
I have the just disgusting and awful
toxic behavior of
expelling my uncomfortable emotions at
people mhm and my inability to tolerate
stress or disappointment or frustration
or expectations not being met or hurt
feelings that creates this sort of
disruption in my body and all of this
stuff it over over the years like I
would expel it at people i' I'd have a
terrible tone of voice I would blame on
my anxiety and I didn't know any better
cuz I didn't understand that healing
actually doesn't start up here it
actually starts in your body and your
ability to not only tolerate emotions
but to regulate the way that you feel
when you experience emotion and my
husband has the opposite way he
withdraws when he feels painful things
in his body he withdraws and so the
thing that has changed everything for me
Lewis is truly
realizing that you know I the second I
started to dig out all the uncomfortable
feelings and the that had happened or
anything else and I learned how to sit
with it I learned how to give myself the
assurance and the love that maybe I
didn't get as a kid that I didn't
experience in other relationships that I
wasn't experiencing that moment learning
how to do that for myself learning how
to regulate my nervous system how to
tolerate the awful stuff that happens to
all of us in
life that has been the biggest game
changer of my relationship cuz I don't
get angry at Chris I completely
understand what you mean when you say
it's really hard to accept a compliment
it's hard to accept a gift you'd rather
have it be about somebody else one of
the biggest breakthroughs I've had in
the last couple years rich is this
Epiphany about my inability to receive
love mhm and the fact that I was
uncomfortable for a long time hearing a
compliment or having somebody say
something nice or having a birthday
party thrown for me or receiving a gift
and I have recently had this
breakthrough because I have learned that
there is a extremely tight connection
between feeling anxious and not allowing
love to come in and so I have this
visual rich and I'm going to explain
this to you
because um I just just had this
emotional experience happen when you
sort of were like pushing away the love
I was trying to to to to shower you with
so I think when you block love like
imagine like there's this closed door
and when somebody tries to link with you
or connect with you or
authentically tell you how amazing you
are if you have a hard time hearing it
you basically have put a solid door
between you and the other person and
I've been working recently with
visualizing The Galley doors in a
kitchen That Swing both ways because
you're very good at giving love you're
very good at giving support you're an
incredibly amazing friend because you're
always there when somebody needs you and
you always open the door to listen to
advise to share and I'm the same way too
and for a long time when somebody would
try to give it back to me the door was
closed
when you place a bet on life and you
place a bet on yourself to face
something to believe that it's all going
to work out that you're going to figure
it out magical things happen magical
things and I'm telling you there is
energy there's an aliveness inside of
you a vibrancy that will come when you
are willing to push through your fears I
know my son wants to go skydiving for
his 18th birthday I made him a promise
I'd do it with it is my biggest fear
other than being buried alive but um I I
do not want to do it I'm starting to
feel a little bit of vomit in the back
of my throat and a nervous stomach just
even thinking about
it but I'm going to do it because I also
want to reach and experience the full
potential of my life and I know every
time that fear holds me back from
reaching out to somebody from saying it
I'm going to go try that thing to
raising my hand when I'm nervous about
how people are going to respond to
jumping into something that I know
nothing
about I'm limiting myself and you're
doing the same thing your mindset and
having a powerful mindset and being
deliberate about what you're going to
think about and what you're not going to
think about it begins the moment you
wake up and believe it or not how you
wake up not when but how you wake wake
up and the first few things that you do
in the morning will dictate your mood
for the rest of the day which based on
science is going to impact your
productivity and it's going to impact
how you feel about your life and it will
also
impact your mindset for the rest of the
day you can think about your morning
routine and whether or not you even have
one in the exact same way that we think
about the brain you're either defaulting
to something that you've always always
done that may not no longer serve you or
you're getting deliberate and choosing
to do something that's more positive and
Powerful because you deserve it and that
starts with your morning routine so if
you're the kind of person where the
alarm goes off and you hit the snooze
and then the alarm goes off again and
you hit the snooze and you know
eventually you roll out of bed and you
step into your day and you maybe drink a
big dark cup of coffee and you skip
breakfast and you skip exercise and
you're tired if that's how you start
your
day your mindset is going to be impacted
by that if your alarm goes off and you
immediately reach for your phone and you
start scrolling through Instagram while
you're in bed and looking at Facebook
and you are putting all kinds of stuff
in your brain that triggers fomo that
triggers insecurity that triggers
anxiety that is going to impact your
mindset for the rest of the day and so
starting tonight I want you to take
control and be more deliberate about
your habits in the morning if you've
been following me for a long time you've
probably heard me talk about the fact
that you should never never never never
hit the snooze button okay and let me
explain why here's how I want you to
wake up when the alarm rings get out of
bed period you want to be a happy person
you want to have a positive mindset you
want to take control of the anxiety the
depression and the stress that you have
do not allow yourself number one when
that alarm goes off to turn it off and
lie in bed and start to ruminate in your
mind about everything that you've got to
do today and how stressed you feel and
to marinate in those negative thoughts I
do not want you to do that you're going
to use the 5sec rule 54 3 2 1 and you're
going to get out of bed the other thing
I do not want you to do is I do not want
you like I used to do I do not want you
when the alarm goes off to reach over
and tap the snooze button the reason why
I do not want you to ever tap the snooze
button is because of how snoozing for a
couple minutes impacts your neurology it
impacts your brain function again this
isn't something I made up this is
wellestablished research you see I used
to be a chronic snooze button hitter
when Chris and I were going through a
really rough time or I notice in times
in my life where I'm feeling stressed
out or overwhelmed when that alarm goes
off there's a small hesitation where I
start to feel a little stressed and
overwhelmed when I think about the day
ahead and it just feels so safe and so
satisfying and and and and and and so
tempting to reach over and hit the
snooze button and do off for 9 minutes
or 15 minutes and then the alarm goes
off again and then I reach over and hit
the snooze button doze off for f 9 to 15
minutes and then the alarm goes off
again and then I reach over and the
reason why it's tempting to do that is
because you're delaying having to deal
with your life you are giving yourself a
false sense of control that I can find 9
to 15 minutes to just avoid having to
deal with what I want to deal with and
so I don't want you to do that and the
reason why I don't want you to ever hit
the snooze button
is because of how dozing off for 9 to 15
minutes impacts the way that your brain
works the way that sleep works is we
fall asleep we sleep in cycles of about
75 to 90 minutes and then we start
another one and we go into another sleep
cycle for 75 to 90 minutes and then we
typically start another one and we start
another sleep cycle that goes 75 to 90
minutes and after two or three sleep
cycles or Heck if you're lucky four of
them your body and brain go into a mode
where for about two hours your brain
just goes into a state where it's
getting ready to wake up so for those of
you that wake up naturally before an
alarm goes off or the alarm goes off and
you've had anywhere from 6 hours plus of
sleep your mind is now in a state it's
not in a sleep cycle where it is ready
to wake up it is ready to start the day
it is ready to be deliberate
if you wake up in that state and then
you reach over and hit the snooze button
and you doze off for 9 to 15 minutes
what do you
suppose your brain starts
again if you're thinking a sleep cycle
you'd be absolutely right and how long
does a sleep cycle last a sleep cycle
lasts 75 to 90 minutes so you drift off
into a sleep cycle your brain does which
lasts 75 to 90 minutes all of a sudden
the alarm goes off 9 to 15 minutes later
your brain is in a sleep cycle you are
in a medical neurological state right
now that scientists call Sleep inertia
it means that by falling into a sleep
cycle and waking yourself up 9 to 15
minutes in it the cortic region of your
brain is now trapped in a sleep cycle
and you realize it takes your brain once
you're awake four hours to shake itself
loose of the state of sleep inertia why
is sleep inertia a Bad Thing studies
prove that when you're in a state of
sleep inertia it impacts your speed of
processing it impacts your ability to
focus it impacts your ability to do any
kind of strategic thinking so for you if
you're a chronic snoozer like I used to
be and you sleep and then the alarm goes
off then you hit snooze then you drift
into a sleep cycle then the alarm goes
off then you hit snooze then you drip
into a sleep cycle and then the alarm
goes off and you get up your brain you
know how you say when you're a snoozer
you're always like I didn't get any
sleep and you feel so groggy and tired
and you keep saying I didn't get enough
sleep last night I didn't get enough
sleep last night guess what has nothing
to do with how much sleep you got it has
to do with the fact that when the alarm
went off instead of getting up you
started another sleep cycle and then
when the alarm went off 15 minutes later
you woke yourself up and now your brain
is trapped in a sleep cycle you're in a
state of sleep inertia at a very young
age I started to realize and I think you
know we all have this Epiphany where we
go oh holy
cow when I get good grades my parents
like me and they love me I get a lot of
positive attention when I make the
football team I'm really feeling loved
when I make the cheerleading squad ooh
when I got into that college or had that
major or made that money or bought that
nice car people really gave me a lot of
positive attention and we hiive
Achievers make a mistake of
fusing what we're doing with our
worthiness we start to believe that we
are only worthy of Celebration support
and love when we are doing
something that is worth celebrating
or worth validating or worth cheering
for and if you don't wake up and
separate the things that you're doing
and striving for and the goals that you
have from your inherent selfworth as a
human
being you will forever feel this sense
that you're not enough you will forever
feel this void because if your selfworth
and your lovability Is Anchored In
achievement even when you make a million
dollars even when you make the New York
Times bestseller list even when you meet
the person of your dreams the second you
achieve that thing you're going to now
look for something else because your
worth as a human being depends on what
you're doing the high five habit is all
about the this radical idea that will
change your life and the idea is
this if you are
breathing you're worthy of
Celebration the mere fact that you exist
is why you are worthy of being loved and
supported and forgiven and it's why you
deserve kindness it's not because you
made it to the gym it's not because
you're making a hundred grand it's not
because you just got promoted should you
celebrate those wins of course but those
wins are not the reason why you're an
extraordinary human being and you know I
had this all knotted up and you know I
wondered why why why did I you know ACH
every time I achieve my goals I would
still see a woman in the mirror that
wasn't enough I was my own worst critic
and by critic this is what I mean I was
relentless
in focusing on what wasn't working I was
relentless in pointing out to myself all
the things I did wrong instead of a
thousand things I was doing right and
that constant grinding
Beatdown was so just much the default I
wasn't even aware of it until I
discovered the power of high-fiving
myself in the mirror and silencing that
critic the belief becomes real when you
start taking actions that are aligned
with the new
belief the new belief becomes real the
new belief becomes encoded in your brain
in your nervous system in your neural
Pathways in your habits in your systems
in the way you talk to yourself your new
belief becomes real when you take
actions that are aligned with the new
belief I did not make this up this is an
entire field of study called behavioral
activation therapy absolutely everything
that I teach you is grounded in
behavioral activation therapy I am
trying to make you
understand that before you feel like the
person you want to become you need to
start acting like the person you want to
become before you feel ready to go to
the gym for the first time in a year
you need to push yourself use the
5-second rule take a 5-second moment of
control 5 4 3 2 1 you need to push
yourself to act like a person now that
has already got a habit of going to the
gym that's how your belief that I
deserve to be healthy and I can figure
out how to do it that's how your belief
goes from just a statement that you say
to a 5-second moment of control 54321
take the action and act like that person
go to the gym for those of you that want
to write for those of you that want to
grow your
business ask yourself what is a person
that is a successful writer do every
single day they
write before you feel like a writer you
need to make yourself take actions that
a writer
takes so that as you stand and you start
to say I can figure out how to write a
book over time I could write a book but
then if you leave the bathroom after
saying that to yourself you now need to
push yourself to sit your ass in a chair
and do what a writer does which is write
about 500 pages of hor before you have
anything worthy of sharing with somebody
else if you struggle with growing your
business I guarantee you you're not
doing the work that would grow your
business you're thinking about all the
reasons why you can't we need to invert
this everybody you need to start saying
I'm I am capable of figuring out how to
grow my business I am capable of pushing
through the fear and picking up the
phone and selling I am able to figure
this out and then you need to 54 3 21
take the actions before you're motivated
before you're ready before like when
you're afraid you can still take the
action when you're hesitating you can
still take action when you don't feel
ready you can still take the action
action is the only way you're going to
change your life and by the way action
is NE necessary you have to decide what
you want to believe and then you got to
do the really hard work to push yourself
to take the action before you're ready
that's the only way that you will change
how you think about yourself how you
think about your life how you think
about your future by deciding what you
want and pushing yourself to take action
5 Seconds at a time when you're scared
when you're anxious when you're not
feeling ready that's how you change
anything and that's how you put it all
together you say the key to successful
days really starts every single morning
what's your routine yeah what do you do
well I want everybody to think about
this like a domino so what is the first
decision that you make in the morning
because that one decision will actually
trigger either negative decisions or
positive decision so decision number one
get your rear end out of bed don't push
snooze absolutely not there's a lot of
brain science around it uh you actually
if you fall back asleep you put yourself
in a state of sleep iner
which makes you uh for the next 4 hours
it makes your brain groggy and it makes
it when you get get up 54 3 21 get out
of that bed then make your bed I'm not
trying to turn you into a Navy SEAL I'm
just saying complete one thing yeah so
the third thing that you're going to do
is I want you to go into the bathroom
and I want you to look in the mirror and
then I want you to say nothing and I
want you to high five the human being
you see in the mirror in the morning
every single morning after you brush
your do you do this every morning let's
take a quick
look right after I brush my teeth look
in the
mirror really look in the mirror and
then oh God I love doing that I love
sending myself into the day with a high
five I got my own back let's go me tell
you the science tell us so for your
entire life you guys you have given
other people a high five right yeah when
you give somebody else a high five what
does it mean you're doing great a girl
good j a girl and what do you and you've
never gone oh I hate you there you go
ever and so the programming is already
in your basil ganglia it's already a
habit to associate this with I love you
go get them you got this I see you when
you do it to yourself something crazy
happens you aim all of that lifetime of
positive neurological programming right
back at yourself something else you said
which I love is a lot of people have
their phone next to their bed and we
always hear don't put it don't put it
but your reasoning behind why you don't
put it like why that isn't the first
thing you see why let me demonstrate
okay most of us either have it here
right or we have it like this right so
what happens is you wake up it's your
alarm yeah you immediately do this right
so the first thing that you are putting
into your brain talk about not making
space for yourself you have just let the
entire world into your mind you have let
work stress you out you have looked at
social media and everybody else's life
and now you think you're behind in some
fake race and so here's the thing you
can't trust yourself I can't trust
myself and so what do you do you leave
it in the other room it is literally in
the bathroom in the bathroom and I leave
the ringer on we have a senior in
college in Los Angeles I need to know
something happens you want to know
something crazy what the Today's Show
will text you all night long but they'll
only call you if it's an emergency if
it's an emergency correct so you'll hear
the call but it's not there so when you
wake up tomorrow morning and literally
go like this and then the alarm rings
and you're kind of screwed over because
now you got to get out of bed to turn
the thing off and you're going to be
like I hate that Mel Robbins person but
by the time you get to the bathroom
guess what you don't care to to be
obsessed correct you have a chance to
turn it off and take the space for
yourself yes and you've already gotten
up there's no snooze you got up yes okay
I hate it I hate it I hate this habit
now you're in it now you're in it we
spend so much time twisting our our El
in knots about unimportant
things and we just talked about how
hideous I'll use the word hideous cuz I
literally looked hideous I mean I not
only had a tomato red face and like
crazy witch hair and uh foggy glasses
and bad breath and impacted sinuses and
probably throwing in a camel toe in
there too I didn't have anything tied
around my
waist
um but not
giving a [__] about that is very
liberating because otherwise I'd be
embarrassed by my own existence walking
down the sidewalk and I would twist
myself in knots worrying about what do I
look like and how red is my face is my
face coming down and maybe I should go
back to the hotel and take a shower and
get this makeup off my face and blow my
nose before I get a cup of coffee and
and all of that energy twisting myself
around what other people may be thinking
rather than just being okay not giving a
it's so liberating there's something
that you want to
believe there's some change that you
want to make there's something that
you're called toward but you're just
scared and it's your old beliefs that
I'm going to regret this or this is
going to be a mistake or what if this
doesn't work out or what if this is the
worst thing I could have ever done or
what if that right and so this is where
I am and I want you to think about what
some change that you want to make in
your
life and the belief that you need to
change in order to really lift yourself
up and support yourself through the
process of changing the belief that I
want to have is that this next chapter
is going to be the best chapter of my
life and that no matter what happens I'm
going to be okay that really it's not
about a house everybody it's about the
people that that are in the house and
now that I'm here alone boy is that true
but I'm so scared to let go you know
everybody where you just know it's kind
of time to let go where it's let go of a
relationship or a place or a friendship
or a career that there's some big move
right and yeah I think I'm taking my
time with leaving a family home because
it is a big decision 24 years in one
place is a big thing having Roots
somewhere is a big thing and so my
belief and the belief that I want to
change is about
okayness it's about the permission to
take a risk and to dream and to trust
myself because you know when I close my
eyes just like when you close your eyes
and think about this change that you
want to make you know what's right for
you yes fa says it feels like a part of
you will die if you leave the truth is a
part of me does need to die because I'm
no longer in that chapter of my life and
I'm holding on to it right why is it so
hard to break through some daily habits
and do things differently why can't I
stay consistent in my daily tasks I'll
tell you why you're frustrated the same
reason why every any organizer is
frustrated because you are trying to
stay consistent in your head and you are
not using simple systems and simple
physical cues to keep you organized and
to keep these changes top of mind that's
it and you are you are managing so much
and you listening to me you don't give
yourself enough credit for how much you
juggling in your own mind stop keeping
Behavior change in your own mind and
let's get it out of your head because I
want you to know something you're not
the
problem you have everything within you
you're not the problem you are capable
of learning new habits you are capable
of making amazing things happen you're
not the problem the problem is that
you're attacking this as an any
organizer you are planning to do this
all in your head and all you need is
Audi systems that keep these new changes
front and center in front of you that's
how you stay consistent stop relying on
Willpower stop relying on having to
remember what you need to do absolutely
not there is no no way you are going to
achieve your goals or stay consistent or
make all those amazing changes that you
want to make that you deserve to have
happen unless you start to implement
systems in your life just to give you a
visual everybody you know tomatoes in
high summer August at a farmer market
bright deep opaque shiny red that was
basically the color of my face my hair
is starting to grow out so the roots are
coming in nice and gray and uh I put on
my glass glasses and they fogged up for
all I know I had a camel toe and I was
walking down uh the sidewalk in La
outside of the yoga studio headed to my
favorite coffee shop to basically get a
cup of liquid caffeinated sugar and I
pulled out that phone because I thought
you know what I did not want to go this
morning my sinuses are bothering me I
know you can relate to that and so I
just start filming and I agree I looked
like absolute but here's what I
think I walk around looking like that so
why would I be worried about putting it
online like if you walk into the grocery
store wearing a pair of
yoga tights and your bra is showing
through your T-shirt and you're sweaty
and your hair is a mess why do you feel
bad putting a photo of yourself looking
like that online like you got to stop
and consider that you're okay going out
in public or being around friends
looking like crap because that's how we
all look in real life but somehow that's
not acceptable on social media and so
it's been very liberating for me to just
go it I don't care what I look like cuz
I walk into a grocery store looking like
this I know I look like who cares but
the public and what I look like in
public is exactly what I'm willing and I
think you should put on social media
because if you don't you're
subconsciously giving a about your
appearance and I think that's really as
you guys keep like teeing up these
examples of where I'm either completely
violating social norms like the no toes
policy which I was unaware of or I am
being really offensive by taking my
shirt off and doing what I thought was a
very polite discreet move of covering my
nipples with my t-shirt so I could get
some sun cuz I feel depressed and
translucent like a gr dolphin living
here in southern Vermont but I think the
real liberating thing about learning how
to give a sh is that you put your energy
toward giving a towards things that
matter and you spend less time draining
your energy on the that really doesn't
matter and one of the things that I gave
up a long time ago Christine is worrying
about what I looked like and maybe it
was because of the experience of being a
commentator on CNN because when I was on
CNN I was on CNN as you know Christine
as an onair commentator a paid legal
commentator there were only five of us
in the entire world that were on that
team and it was a really cool job
analyzing some of the biggest cases um
of our
time uh I noticed something that
whenever I would be on TV and I would
have an opinion about particularly a
case that people were really hot about
like um Trayvon Martin's murder or what
happened in Ferguson or Freddy gray or
Tamir rice and I'm a criminal defense
attorney and so I am adding in
commentary as a defense attorney I
noticed that when people criticized me
they never criticize what I
said people on Twitter or on social
media here I am on television talking
about his very serious topic I take the
job very seriously they're like y old
bag you know have you seen your neck you
know who like just dragging my down my
jowls that look like saddle bags or my
saggy ass turkey gizzard neck or just
constantly trashing me that I just
learned how to tune it out and I started
to not care and there's something very
liberating about leaving an exercise
class and your mascara from last night
is running down your face like Dracula
and going and getting your coffee anyway
you know why because you don't give a sh
what the other people who are standing
in line around you think about the fact
that your mascara is running and half of
them you're probably never going to see
again anyway so who gives a first we're
going to talk about globally how I want
you to think about being able to focus
your
attention and get things done okay and
this is on a daytoday basis first of all
when I talk about productivity and the
ability to focus your attention on a
day-to-day basis I want you to
understand a simple fact
in order to get things done in order to
direct your focus and move through a
task you are going to require some brain
power and so I want you to think about
your brain like a a car engine right and
a car engine is what you need uh in a
car to power you forward and your brain
is like an engine that will power you
forward to help you get tasks done now
an engine requires fuel right and sure
enough your brain has a certain amount
of fuel so imagine that you got like a
tank that has fuel in it in your brain
okay and as you wake up and as you go
through your day and as you direct your
attention on things guess what happens
to that fuel in your brain it starts to
drain and so I want you to know this
because the tactics and the tool TOS
that I'm about to teach you relate to
the fuel in your brain and what times of
day you have the most fuel what times of
day you are more likely to be able to
focus okay and what do you think
everybody is the best time of day for
your brain and for the amount of fuel
that you have in your brain
naturally in order to be able to tap
into it and drive your focus at
something that's important to you I love
this you guys are right Laura says my
brain is mush by the end of the day
everybody's saying morning morning
morning I see somebody saying I feel
like I'm on empty this is a really good
analogy because there are times where
you feel like your brain is full of gas
and you're able to direct your attention
and focus and then there are times where
you're like Jesus I feel like I'm
running on empty I'm running on fumes
here and you're absolutely right
everybody it is mornings when you wake
up generally what the research shows is
that your brain is primed to be able to
focus for the first 4 hours of the day
the first four hours of the day tend to
be for most of us the time of day when
your brain has the most fuel and and
when your speed of processing is awesome
and when you are able to direct your
attention at what you need to be focused
on okay so now there's a caveat to this
you can
manufacture boosts of productivity and
boosts of feeling like you've got a
little bit more brain power number one
immediately after you exercise so if you
have a burst of cardio 30 minutes is
what a lot of the research says but if
you have a burst of cardio you will get
a little bit of increase in fuel another
thing that helps is getting outside
getting outside uh when you start to
feel your energy and your focus start to
go to empty getting outside is another
way to give yourself a boost of brain
power my husband and I have just uh
bought a house in Vermont
and I know you guys you know are in your
new home it's an incredible thing to do
it is our dream house it's the house
that his parents built it's the family
house we not only were able to purchase
this thing we've been able to completely
renovate it make it our own this place
is the closest place to God that I have
ever been we sit nestled between
mountains with 140 mile view straight
down a valley with cascading like it is
just spectacular when I would sit in
therapy sessions eight years ago and my
therapist would ask me to come up with
like a um you know like a totem or a
spiritual guide or Vision whatever for
truth or God or what it's always this
few and so lo and behold eight years
later we freaking live there and I'm
sitting on this covered deck looking
down the valley my daughter is sitting
next to me her other daughter who lives
in Boston who's 23 and it's
Sunday and normally on
Sundays I'm not even present on Sundays
because I'm now got the Sunday scaries
I'm now thinking about the week ahead
she is starting to now do that okay I
got to get going I got I got to pack the
car I got to get going I got I got a big
week of work this week and and it's 7:30
in the morning on a spectacular
day and the energy is starting and I
recognize the energy because that is the
campaign of misery
that I have lived with for 50 years and
I'm sitting there and I'm thinking oh
this is
interesting that's
me and then I stopped in that moment Jay
and I thought I don't feel that right
now I just feel that exactly where I am
looking at this
view is
exactly where I'm supposed to be and it
was so profound it's almost like that
moment with where eart tole has on the
bench in the beginning of the Power of
Now where I have this profound
experience where I think wait a minute
is this what happiness
is that I'm not 15 steps
ahead I'm just able to be right here
without the anxiety without the stress I
mean that is like a revolutionary
experience for me I don't think I had
ever not felt the default of a revved up
nervous system an anxious mind or a
to-do list that was a mile long and I
don't want to go back to that sort of
frenetic busyness that creates chronic
stress and you know the challenge for me
right now is how do I stay in a space
that's that's happy because I love the
game of building a business I love
pushing myself I love like and I
realized oh wait you actually need both
you need deep spiritual quiet time and
you need the busyness of Los Angeles or
Boston or New York in small Sprints but
that can't be your default anymore woman
there's somebody really close to us and
our family who has had this massive
uptick of anxiety happen and it has been
so debilitating that this person has
actually taken an entire week off of
work and I've been thinking that's
actually the opposite of what you should
do because if you are scared that you're
going to have a panic attack at work so
you don't go to work you're making the
anxiety bigger than you avoiding that
thing or avoiding the situation that may
happen makes the fear bigger I've been
in this boat too where the anxiety has
been so debilitating that I I've
actually had anxiety so bad that it
built and built and built and built up
inside me when I was a seconde law
student that I convinced myself that
there was no way that I could get on a
plane and go to Albuquerque New Mexico
where I had landed a summer job and be
able to live and work on my own and I
talk about avoidance I called that law
firm and told them that I had had a
family
emergency and I had to not come this was
two days before I was supposed to get on
the plane now and so I have done this
over and over and over and over again in
my life and I can't wait until you
unpack all the forms of avoidance but
you're right you do link
up this act of oh my gosh if I just
don't do it then I'm going to be okay
but you actually make it worse if you
want to
know how you are showing up and if you
want to truly
improve how you participate in that
relationship simply send your partner a
text that says how can I be a better
partner to
you and then ask for specifics and Chris
would tell me well you could flatten the
cardboard boxes you could throw out your
Kleenex you could put your phone down at
6:00 at
night you could um uh you could take the
dog for a walk in the morning you could
be more present you could like he he
would have a whole list of things that
would make a difference and most of us
don't bother to ask so that's number one
you're not even asking and when you ask
that
question your job is to listen and
elicit more things for you to do it is
not to defend yourself or to give
feedback Deborah says what about
complaining about things that genuinely
take time to resolve like I'm getting
over being
sick let me ask you a
question does complaining about being
sick actually help you get
better it's a fair
question you're allowed to complain if
it's productive if it makes you feel
better to
go and saying it is
helpful
if doing that makes you feel even worse
try not to do
it say things like boy I'm on day three
of this I must be getting
better boy uh the meds are going to kick
in at any
moment you know when it starts Chris is
looking at me like what are you talking
about no it's just somebody mentioned do
thoughts count you know it's outbound
sort of out outward complaining but then
there complaining in your own mind of
course thoughts count cuz you know what
you complain about the most yourself
your body your
intelligence what you just said the fact
that you didn't go to the gym the fact
that you didn't uh do what you said you
were going to do the beating yourself up
as a form of complaining because you're
expressing
dissatisfaction for
yourself and the problem with all this
is that when you do it habitually or
when you complain
as just a default mode and you don't
realize how much you're doing it you're
allowing your mind to filter the world a
certain way and you're allowing yourself
to live in existence where your own
thoughts are
poisonous if you feel like hell and you
got the flu and you've just thrown up in
the toilet complain all you want vent
all you want you just earned that but at
some point you're going to have to stop
feeding the monster and putting poison
in your own mind and you're going to
have to teach yourself how to start to
find Milestones that are positive so
that you can become healthier so that
you can change how you think how you
create a better life with goal setting
because goals setting from this point
forward must be a part of your life if
you want to feel a greater sense of
purpose and meaning period and so I want
you to come back to this episode I want
you to bookmark it I want you to share
this with people that you care about if
you've got somebody like I do who's a
college senior and as they approach
graduation and they start to feel like
they're about to have a quarter life
crisis and they're lost you know what
they need they need goals if you have a
friend going through divorce you know
what they need they need goals if you're
bored in Life or feeling stuck or you
got to hit the reinvention button you
know what you need you need goals and
you can relisten to this every single
corner at any moment in your life and
walk yourself through this very simple
but powerful and life-changing research
to get very clear about what you want
and why you want it and how you're going
to go achieve it now speaking about the
how you want to know how habits are how
you achieve goals systems are how you
make it
easier I show up here cuz I do believe
in you you I don't care what's happened
to you you cannot convince me that you
cannot change I have way too much
evidence on my side you only have your
experience I've got an army of a million
people that I've seen change and so I
know you can change because I know you
can take the actions to make your mind a
better place you can take the actions to
make your life feel better you can take
the actions to improve your relationship
with with yourself and this is the most
exciting part this is the thing I am
working on myself day in and day out you
can take the actions that reclaim your
brain that reprogram your mind and that
make your mindset and your thoughts work
for you I mean all this is made up that
we're saying
anyway so if you can think bad thoughts
why not think good
ones does it actually make you happy to
tell yourself that you suck and that
there's something wrong with
you and is it even
true so if you can make that crap up if
you can adopt what somebody else says
about can't you make up your own of
course you can if you struggle with
being kind to
yourself it is never too early or too
late to have an enormous breakthrough in
your relationship to yourself and this
is really important it's really
important because based on the research
there was this massive study done in the
UK where they took took a look at
absolutely every single Behavior or
attitude change you could make or you
could practice in terms of improving
your life and they looked at everything
they looked at changing your diet
practicing gratitude having a meditation
practice exercising regularly seeing
your friends more all the things that we
know we should be doing right but do you
know that the single Behavior change
that has the biggest and most profound
impact on your quality of your
day-to-day life is simply being kinder
to
yourself yeah that's right according to
the research being kinder to yourself
learning how to accept and love yourself
it is the biggest mover in terms of your
happiness meaning confidence all of it
and the sad thing about the study is
that habit of being kinder to yourself
of accepting yourself of loving yourself
it's the one we practice the least the
5c rule leverages proven principles in
modern psychology and there literally
hundreds of examples that I could point
to first let's talk about two concepts
one called locus of control the second
called a bias toward action so a locus
of control is a foundational principle
in Psychology you should Google it back
in the day researchers figured out that
there are basically two kinds of people
people that believe that they're in
control of their lives and folks that
believe that life is just happening to
them and they're a victim of whatever
might happen now when you look at these
two types of people people that have an
internal locus of control a belief that
they're in control of their lives
they're happier they're more successful
more productive so the question becomes
how do you create an internal locus of
control in yourself the answer is simple
it's called a bias toward action so a
bias toward action is a psychological
principle that means you're the kind of
person that has a bias toward taking
action instead of a bias toward thinking
how do you create a bias toward action
you guessed it the 5c rule the five
second rule is a tool that will teach
you how to take action and over time as
you use it you not only learn how to
take action you become the kind of
person that operates with a bias toward
taking action and when you take action
over and over and over on your instincts
on your desires on your commitments
guess what you get you build an internal
locus of control you become the kind of
person that believes that you're in
control of your life because you're
proving it to yourself one 5-second
decision at a time and the other thing
you have to understand is that there are
going to be legs of your journey in life
and this is one of the hardest things
where people are going to pull off and
take a different route that's okay they
may come back at another time that's
okay and you know the final thing that
I wanted to say about this is it's a
very simple exercise that you can do
with somebody and this helps somebody
who is either struggling with happiness
and doesn't know how to get started or
is struggling with
confidence and is not able to take
action or who is resisting the changes
that you are doing and you would love to
see them
do we did this with our daughter who uh
is now 23 and last summer when she
graduated from college really unhappy I
mean two years of college had been
imploded and she was extremely depressed
and basically just drank her way through
it and graduated and was not happy big
life change nothing was going according
to plan she had planned this huge trip
to go to Cambodia and do a big service
trip for 4 months that wasn't going to
happen just
lost and so Chris and I sat with her for
a couple hours and then I said and she's
like I don't know what to do I'm 22 I'm
stuck I'm miserable I don't even know
how to start and I said I actually think
you do I think you're just scared take
out a blank piece of paper draw a line
down the center on the left hand side I
want you to write happy me now close
your
eyes and think about a time that you
remember being happy or more confident
or Alive it could be any word you want
right and you might have to go back to
Childhood our daughter closed her eyes
and she said it was senior year in high
school and I said okay so write down all
of the things that you were doing in a
week of your life senior year in high
school just describe your life for me oh
I got up at and and do it in detail
everybody I got up at 7:00 a.m. or 6:30
I was was leaving the house by 7:00 I
was with my friends all day I was
looking forward to go to college I was
playing varsity lacrosse I was
exercising six days a week I was only
partying with friends twice a week I you
know was in a healthy dating
relationship I ate four dinners a night
at home like
just great write down what your life
looks like now I sleep till 1 I drink
every day I feel like I don't see my
friends cuz everybody's scattered now
that we graduate I don't have anything
to look forward to my my trip to
Cambodia is canceled I'm not
exercising okay compare the
two your own life experience offers the
map and we want to over complicate these
big words like happiness I know I did
for decades or
confidence it's
actually found in the little
things if you do this simple exercise of
drawing a line down a piece of paper and
you write write down what life looked
like in great detail when did you wake
up when did you go to bed how are we
with friends family what were you doing
for work exercise what were you
eating if you then compare that to what
life looks like now you now know what to
do and the fact is your whole life is
the little things it's when you wake up
it's the first thing you look at it's
what you do with your body it's how you
greet your spouse it's how you talk to
yourself it's what you say to yourself
when you look in the mirror it's the
mood that you walk in to work with
intentionally it's how you greet your
animals or your roommate when you end
the day it's the tone of voice that you
use that's your whole
life and if you were to just take the
time and intentionally write down a few
simple things that you do when you're
happy in life and you were to focus for
the next seven days on just adding one
of those in a day you would be very
surprised how getting some of the little
things right actually starts to turn
your life in a completely different
direction worrying is wasting time it's
robbing you of what you want to do in
your life and it's making you suffer in
a needless way look I don't want you to
get to the end of your life and look
back and think I wish I hadn't wasted so
much of my precious life on stuff that
didn't matter I wish I didn't let all
that stupid worrying keep me from doing
the things that I always dreamt about
doing I'm here to tell you that you can
learn how to switch your thoughts to
something more productive and optimistic
this is great news worry is a hackable
thing and I'm going to use a ton of
Science and proven experience to show
you just how to hack it using one
magical tool and here's the great news
once you learn how worry starts you can
use that knowledge to make it stop you
can practice this magical tool every day
to quiet your mind I mean just imagine
that a quiet
mind wow I know exactly how you feel I
mean I know how exhausting and
frustrating it is to constantly be
trapped in the grinding cycle of
worrying about everything how do I know
this I lived it I've always been worried
I mean if you could be a baby that
worries that was me I'm sure at 11
months when my mom was running late to
heat up my pureed carrots and potatoes I
was probably thinking is she coming back
where is she I'm starving I mean I might
just starve to death here I think she
hates me she's left she maybe she's
angry about the face I made as I tried
the pued snow peas for lunch oh my gosh
what do I do uh I I have to find a new
family to feed feed me how am I going to
find my new family I got no connections
no money I I'm wearing a diaper I can't
even walk yet I'm going to starve to
death in the next 24 hours that was baby
mail and that was just the beginning I
mean I was just kind of warming up for a
life of worry on a very elite
professional level you know as a little
kid I worried about everything from the
teacher's reaction to whether or not the
kid in the stall next to me was going to
hear me fart when I got to Middle School
it was all about whether or not my tough
skin jeans were cool or my acne or my
New Perm that I immediately regretted
when I was in college I was worried if I
studied enough for the test if I was
going to flunk out if I was going to go
blind from the grain alcohol I drank
from the garbage can at that frat party
I worried if I had enough gas in the car
to get to the grocery store the truth
about worrying is once you let it start
to spin it just spins out of control I'm
sure you know this I mean worry has
tormented me since I was a kid it
tormented me as a teen in my 20 20 my
30s hell my 40s and if I can go from
having this worry as my torturous
default and learn how to interrupt it
and redirect it and program a positive
mind you can too the second you catch
yourself wearing when you feel your mind
spin when you feel your shoulders pinch
up towards your ears like new earrings
and you feel your jaw clench and wait
there's more you feel yourself starting
to get heavy and paralyzed into it and
those worries start to spin in your mind
here's exactly what you're going to do
it's just six magical words it
encapsulates incredible research it's so
simple you can do it and don't worry
it's going to
work here are the six magical words
you're going to say to yourself every
time you worry what if it all works
out that's
it what if it all works out
look I know what you're thinking you
feel let down right now that's because
you're worried it's not going to work
but what if it all works out what if
these simple stupid six words actually
work what if trying this works out you
just heard me say the words what if it
all works out and you know what your
response was well I don't think it's
going to work out that's why I'm
worrying you got to trust me on this
your worries sound just as dumb as this
magical tool does you have just listen
to your worry for so long that you
believe it let's detour into the lane of
anxiety of patterns and Trauma uhhuh and
talk about why people self-sabotage yes
people don't
self-sabotage
intentionally nobody wakes up in the
morning and says today I'm going to
screw up my life right that's what I'm
going to do I'm going to drink myself on
the ground I'm going to cheat on my wife
I'm going to embezzle for my company I'm
going to lie to everybody about how I'm
actually feeling I'm going to stop
taking my meds I'm going to kick the dog
like nobody does
that what happens is people get
triggered and they react and then they
fall into Old patterns mhm and so what
happens I believe in
relationships in particular or jobs
where you're like this time it's going
to be different is it's different for
the first 3 to six months when it's
novel MH and when you're intentional and
when everything counts but then when you
got to face
yourself then when it becomes like part
of your life you get lazy and you slip
into Old patterns or when the stakes get
really high let's say you're somebody
who had a parent die early or your dad
abandoned the family and you're scared
to love somebody and so you fall deeply
for somebody and then what gets
triggered is this tremendous fear that
they're going to Le
yeah because that's your lived
experience and if you go back to what
you did as a child to cope with that
fear that somebody's going to leave
that's the exact pattern that you will
repeat as an adult MH the only way to
end this or to try to get your arms
around it is to attack it
holistically because so much of this
happens at the subconscious level and it
also it gets triggered first by your
nervous system not than aware of it for
some incredible taus motivation check
the video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there having a purpose that
transcends yourself is really important
in terms of your own mental health your
physical health your longevity and if
you're striving for something that is
not authentic for you and